le gouvernement annonce la mise en place
d'une commission denquête france
charbonneau a accepté de présider cette
commission sans aucune hésitation
mais elle a d'abord demandé l'appui de
sa famille ensuite je me suis assurée
d'avoir la collaboration de deux
enquêteurs d'expérience et qui était
spécialisée en matière de crime organisé
parce que les différents volets de notre
mandat commander ça au total plus de 140
personnes dont une vingtaine
d'enquêteurs surtout des policiers et
autant d'avocats comptable analystes
ingénieurs se sont activés dans l'ombre
plus de six mois avant le début des
audiences publiques très vite l'un en un
désaveu du vch crise d'un dès le début
des audiences la stratégie des
procureurs est clair puisque vous dites
c'est dans le but d'obtenir des contrats
nature professionnelle
provoquer des révélations en cascade de
la part des entrepreneurs juste le
montant la halle et un aux partis
politiques c'est sûr que ceux qui ont
ouvert la voie ont été déterminants et
je pense plus particulièrement un
ingénieur michel à l'ong je pense que au
delà des rumeurs on le constate et leur
expliquer la collusion au sein des
firmes d'ingénieurs vous avez aussi lino
zambito qui a expliqué la collusion et
la corruption
donc ce que vous dites que tous les
échelons des employés de la ville il y
avait des gens qui étaient corrompus à
plumes vous avez aussi bernard trépanier
avec sa célèbre phrase un james zhan qui
marquait vraiment stack way la culture
du boys club à la ville de montréal et
le favoritisme dans l'octroi de contrats
et puis vous avez aussi une phrase
marquante moi qui m'a marqué qui est
celle de nicolo milioto vous me respecte
et je le respecte pour mu mal à trotter
du peu de mal à la même façon alors ça
c'était à donner froid dans le dos
les retombées financières de la
commission sont énormes aux dires de la
présidente
la commission a été exactement 44
millions mais si vous comptez qu'un des
impacts les plus importants a été la
baisse des coûts de construction dans
les contrats publics de terre pour cent
juste ça ça représente plusieurs
milliards de dollars et je vous parlais
pour marianne mais mon travail après la
commission charbonneau simon tremblay
est devenu le directeur des services
juridiques de la ville de laval les
sommes dues à ce jour parce qu'il ya
plusieurs pour cependant encore à ses
environs selon mon estime il bien
imparfait là environ 145 millions donc
on est déjà bon qu'avec 100 millions
d'euros venant dans le var les retrouver
judiciaire directement aujourd'hui par
la commission sont moins claires est ce
que la juge charbonneau aurait souhaité
que plus de responsables de la
corruption soient mises en prison oui
pour certains procès sabine et eidos a
moins bien et et où je peux mais il faut
faire attention à avoir à ne pas se
limiter à la vision punitive de
l'exercice le travail de trouver des
stratagèmes quant à moi vous avez
complètement devoir de réserve n'empêche
de répondre à ces questions on peut
également penser à tous les autres
professionnels lors des ingénieurs qui a
été même sous tutelle qui
poursuivit en devant le comité conseil
de discipline je pense près de 300
ingénieurs je pense que ça donnait une
prise de conscience collective
de l'étendue et de la nature de la
corruption qui était qui était là depuis
des décennies puis ça crée un désir de
mieux faire la présidente ne souhaite
pas revenir sur le coup de théâtre du
commissaire renaud lachance qui avait
exprimé sa dissidence sur les liens
entre le financement des partis
politiques provinciaux et l'obtention de
contrats publics en ce qui concerne le
provincial les biens étaient indirectes
c'était après avoir obtenu un certain
nombre de contrats publics
les gens étaient appelés à passer à la
caisse et c'est dans le rapport et c'est
dans ce sens là que c'est un ce sont des
liens indirects elle ne dira rien non
plus sur sa décision de ne pas inviter
le premier ministre jean charest a
témoigné
quant à savoir si la corruption est
maintenant oreiller au québec dix ans
après france charbonneau et son collègue
ne se font pas d'illusions
on espère que les gens qu'ils gouvernent
ont compris messages de toute époque là
comme son charbonneau le journalisme
enquête les faits qu'on appelait les
faits marteau l'escouade marteau
tout l'amalgamme de sow qui fait une
erreur ça c'était aujourd'hui je crois
est-ce que ça se continue je ne sais pas
mais c'est sûr que là où il ya de
l'homme il y aura toujours de l'hommerie
mais c'est pour ça que je dis qu'il
faudra toujours rester vigilant
[Musique]